hannah damals lukas herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video auf
meinem canalis zusammen mit der teddy
hallo du redest immer so laut alter
teils mol wir haben uns hier mal wieder
täglich in vorbereiteten einmal luca
einmal sandra auf meiner seite auch
bekommen dann auch sandra seite wir
bekommen durch fragen gestellt von einer
person hinter der kamera
und ich würde sagen wir fangen
[Musik]
so weiß man sich der direktor person
gehört das beschreibt das nicht ab bei
der wert aber eine nummer haben
ich habe aktuell seit freitag ein user
ich kann jetzt schon sagen weil jeder
frage wird einfach wanderer bei
rauskommen werde er in promis zusammen
warum denn nur ein traum
ich glaube ich weiß es nicht haben
obwohl doch ich glaube ich brauche ja du
ja ist denn dein lieblings promi liebe
[Musik]
geburtstag des jeweils anderen
verwerfungen du sagst du sagen das ist
der 20 der zweite weihnachtstag sind
noch immer auf der toilette ein
ja ja ja ja ja ja gerade sind wir weiter
macht spontan er ein held
[Musik]
die sache hat sich genommen das sorgt ja
doch beide glaube ich ein schönes wetter
wochenende ist noch garnicht wochenende
jeden tag
ja ich kann mich ja blog hat noch nie
würden gesehen ich glaube wenn sich luca
flirten sicher es ist der größte moment
in meinem leben ist dass wir zu sein
wird wie fachlich du kannst dich sagt
worden bist irgendwie sie du willst du
ja du hast die du hast du studiert frage
ich doch auch nicht dass ich künftig
will wo ich habe schon eine bessere duca
gelingt ganz schlimm
dann sind jetzt single hello hello die
frank versteht nicht dein partner ist
auch immer ach so trittin scheißdreck ob
sie etwas ganz normales ich finde da
muss man sich auch nicht verschieben du
hast sowieso fremdscham verlor seiner
mutter auf den h steht und ich dachte
mir okay was stadt gerne länger und
handy
[Musik]
oder tina muss geführt werden
[Gelächter]
ja ich gebe es jetzt zeigen wir fragen
wo jeder sich selbst schickt auch immer
ganz leicht sich seine nächste cd gruppe
a propos diese wir haben auch ein foto
von sandra als die letzten von peter
zurück braucht man gar nicht zu sagen
auch der richtige was ich gesagt habe
ich dachte mir einen selber ist doch
schon selber ja ich hab dich fragen
nicht verschont das haben jetzt gezeigt
wenn du hübsch breit wo es einen großen
möglich hätte ich einfach ich antworte
jeden hier hat auch in sherman laser
luca schreibt allem und folgt wie viele
kinder willst und besonders henleys
alter
das ist eine ganz klare nummer ja wirst
du dich da auch sehen mit kakerlaken
essen und so nehme ich würde einfach
schön und nicht bis zum 1 weight
watchers nur meine zwei wochen weight
watcher groß berkel der liebe heiraten
[Musik]
ganz traurig doch dann passte zu dem
kommentar dass wir so stehen jetzt
merkte man der männlicher ist dann
brauchst du ja ich würde nicht wieder
auf den beinen weil ich nie mehr vor da
fliegen wir doch gerade hat 'hallo'
gesagt ich würde den film hat er gar
nicht schauen ich weiß nicht wieso
schaut man auch auf filme sich täglich
weiter wochen den kick
[Musik]
was ist denn dein kick was bringt dich
auf 118 crafter videos gucken
du hast eine unterhose auf ebay gestellt
130000 euro renner geworden sondern um
das was wir kriegen ja also wirklich fan
oder nicht
über 20 muskulös groß schwarze haare
[Musik]
obwohl gut doch wenn wir bei hast du
schon mal hätte ich jetzt gedacht so auf
malle nach nach megapark
es war nicht mehr weit bis zur
ausrichtung des zelle karneval
wie gefällt das lassen wir es einfach
mal so stehen er werde sich eher nach
anfrage
damit habe ich auch ultra gar kein
problem
ultra können ich steh auf fkk ich liebe
es leuten abzusehen ist dass da stelle
ich mir sogar recht als das netbook
besitzt du bist irgendwie nicht so am
startgeraden ja ich bin auch froh
darüber
[Musik]
er hatte den besseren nur nein nein da
sieht man ganz ehrlich die am rand
absolut du kannst gar warum warum hasst
mich du bist eher youtuber als das ist
ja ja stimmt die checks noch so häufig
deine die ms mehrere es glaubt doch ich
habe dir doch mal gesagt ich aber dem
lukas dienstag war passiert sandra aber
ich glaube der falschen betreibt sie
nicht mehr das flugzeug rein ich sehe
den sinn wieder nicht das ist wieder so
eine kick sache dass manche leute das
braucht nur zeit geld davon aus dem
flugzeug zu springen
genau sie mit so cacau film du zahlst
geld dafür dass du schwitzt und das hier
dass du angst albträume tricks warum wie
können dass leute entscheiden wir
brauchen ab und zu einfach den kick
meine omas auch 30 mal vom falschen 30
viele sprünge gemacht
das ist jetzt wirklich so wieder war es
schwierig dafür gleich wieder sind ca ja
ich würde ganz klar sagen
beides beiden ich glaube du doch mehr
stimmst du kleiner besonders großer
traum ist mega park song tatsächlich da
schon mit cowboystiefeln brutaler werden
[Musik]
ich glaube ich ja weil du wirst trotzdem
nehmen ja das ist luca das ist genau in
worte gefasst werden
[Musik]
jede hauptstadt gibt die so wird nicht
nur für die wand schauen
das saarland zu können habe sie halt
gemacht bei kindern
da bin ich 32 zu ihrer liebe zum richtig
gute fragen wirklich das ist zwar und
kommentiert sonntag
letzte woche lukas ich wünsche mir dann
ziemlich alle letzte kommentar dallas
abonnieren man channel gibt in dem video
daumen hoch wenn ihr wollt